there was a really pretty girl she asked
me if I was going to the audition that
night they wanted us to sing and dance
I'm like jock from New Jersey well I
mean singing dance the first thing I did
I was a dead body on a soap opera here
in New York then I was doing screen test
and then I got a soap opera and I did
that for three and a half years at 25 I
quit the soap I moved to LA and I had an
agent but for five years pretty much
nothing happened but I would go to this
this acting class that Melanie Griffith
who was in something while she she and
her then-husband Steven Bauer would go
to him so I went to this guy Harry and I
just studied and nothing would really
happen for five years so I was 30 I went
home for Christmas and my parents were
saying you know they said well Melanie's
in it why don't you call her up and ask
my snow I'm not gonna get started like
that having her do it and the in the
acting class all the actors were saying
that the guys that I studied with was
saying did you go up for something wild
you should go up for something wild
you're you know you're right for it and
blah blah blah well I called my agent my
agent couldn't get me in I called
Melanie up finally got the nerve up to
do that and she said yeah of course they
will ray and it turned out that she had
a bad experience with the guy that
played her husband so she asked Jonathan
can I have put can I have so I want some
say in it he said yeah of course of
course so I went in and and met him on a
Monday Thursday I get a call come in and
read wit for Jeff Dan with Jeff Daniels
who's also in the movie
you white VIP just don't do it and do a
scene there so I'm watching teats Johnny
Carson that night at jeff daniels comes
on and he was just so he was talking
about woody and jack because he had just
done the Purple Rose of Cairo and he had
just done in terms of endearment two
great movies and he was great in them so
I'm selling my gosh you gotta read but
this guy's tomorrow something I do
push-ups and looking at my lines again I
August and I went and read with him but
because I was I guess when studying with
air I was just ready and and wanting it
and then I got a call and he told me
that was the first one I just did my
homework and was where I was supposed to
be and you know he was with my wife and
Melanie wasn't played my wife in it or I
played her husband and so it was you
know then intense
[Music]
no no but it has to do more with
something personal that was going on at
that time so when I did go to see it my
mother was sick and she we couldn't stay
and it just
I've never seen it getting thrown out of
baseball was like having part of me
amputated I've heard that old men wake
up and scratch it she legs that have
been dust for over 50 years that was me
i bat Mir a bat right-handed I throw
left-handed Shoeless Joe batted
left-handed and threw right-handed so I
was I did they put me at USC with with
the coach of USC who had won 13 national
champions and there was this guy Donnie
Buford who used to play for the Orioles
he was his assistant so I was practicing
left handed and obviously I thought they
would just do camera tricks well the
producers and the director came down one
day to watch you know how I was coming
along and they saw since I wasn't left
in but they they batted really stilted
back then so I thought we could get away
with it
and because it was only my third movie I
wasn't going to say no this is what you
have to do they said doesn't matter you
you know she was Joe never came back
from the dead you could bat right-handed
and a bat left hand throw right head
that so but no I've never seen it
I wasn't script savvy and I couldn't
imagine this guy digging up his
cornfield to put a ball fall field there
because he was hearing things it just
sounded so silly to me I just didn't
didn't get it but you know I learned
quickly that I was wrong and what really
convinced me was because James Earl
Jones was in it I knew Kevin because we
all used to hang out playing paddle
tennis and when nothing was happening
for
any of us Andy Garcia Steven Bauer
they're all guys that ended up doing
movies and we had this group before
anything happened and that's what we saw
I knew Kevin and then our Burt Lancaster
is gonna be in this like is well I guess
they think it's good Oh Who am I to say
tis silly
no it's Iowa Hill Pileggi who wrote the
script he also wrote the book when I got
the call it was called wise guy but
because there was a movie wise guy they
they they somehow came up with
Goodfellas and he Nick when I got it he
gave me all the tapes that he had of
Henry when he was interviewing him for
the book so I listened to that over and
over and over again it was like little
cassettes so I would you know put it in
the car and and cuz it kept the movie
kept getting pushed so I was just in
Jersey just just waiting at my house and
I would listen to the tapes and and
Andry hill while he was telling his
story was eating potato chips and it's
so annoying to listen to something
chomping somebody chomping on potato
chips while they're telling stories
about their life now I asked Marty
should I should I meet him I wanted to
meet him but but they didn't want me to
do that so I did it so again you know
the way that I've learned is just doing
homework the more you think about
something the more it's gonna mean
something to you when I mean something
to you hopefully to mean something to an
audience
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
funny guy shows a great storyteller and
he told the story about how what we did
for the funny guy thing had happened to
him when he was at a restaurant or
something so he was telling that story
and morning said you know what it would
be great to put it where they put it in
the movie and saw it first what we do is
we just improv dit and improv him
probably improv and then when when Marty
was happy with the way it was they put
it in stone they wrote it out and that's
what we ended up doing I mean we played
around with it at the end the ending was
a little there was some improv there
that we did but it was great it was
great you know Bob kind of kept a
distance kind of like how Jimmy probably
was with with Henry but I mean like I
can't I don't know that for sure but I
did this charity thing the other night
and a cop came up to me and he said he
was an undercover cop that knew all
those guys so and he said he said like
the movies extremely accurate but I've
worked with Marty doing it and Nick
pileggi who did the thing I wrote the
book you know they didn't make stuff up
tell me tell me what's funny
kids'll caddy its autonomy it was fun it
was just really fun because there's
there's something very energizing about
playing pretend with people who really
are in it and you know you don't realize
the cameras or any of that stuff you're
just doing what you have to do I mean
that's what it's all about so it's it's
great doing that and then you know I'm
working with Scorsese us you know you
know you could jump up to a building off
a building and you knew he was gonna
catch him because he's just just an
unbelievable director yeah I didn't want
to do that one at all because everyone
knew since Sinatra I don't sound like
him I don't look like him the only thing
we have in common were both from Jersey
and we both say the F word I I'm gonna
laugh instead of cry
I'm gonna take the town and turn it
upside down but originally his daughters
asked me to do the miniseries when they
used to have miniseries on TV and I just
same reasons no no I don't want to do
that so they asked me if I wanted to do
the HBO thing and I just said no and and
they asked me again no no I don't want
to do it and I'm realized wait what I
keep saying no to this because I was
afraid of judgment one of the things
that you can't be as an actor if you're
afraid of what people are gonna say then
you know and he was just such an iconic
and you know everybody but not everybody
heard or knew this story so I just said
alright yeah okay
I'll do it I'll just just I'm an actor
and and I there were so there's so many
books on him I read lots of books I
listened to his music constantly i
lip-sync although I sang out loud to a
Frank Sinatra imitator so wasn't even
him because his music was too expensive
at the time it probably still is I first
listened to the music at Capitol Records
in LA where he recorded something you
know a few of his albums so just being
in there just seeing what it was like
because I was never in never listen to
anyone making music before
[Music]
and God
I live
which I assume starts oh my god he is
just unbelievable because to me that was
my parents music and then I would put on
another station or cassette I just had
to take it out right away because
there's nothing as rich and emotional
and and the story that they tell within
the song as what he did he's just
unbelievably great
[Applause]
[Music]
Ridley Scott directed at another great
director so when when it came time to do
that scene uh so Ridley how we gonna do
this because I I played a heart surgeon
in a movie way before that and I would I
just became fascinated with watching
heart surgeries and then I also watched
someone's brain that you know that his
head was open and he was a awake while
they were operating on this guy's brain
it was at a VA hospital in LA so I said
really all right so I know obviously I
have to be awake because we have the
scene but how how do you want me to play
this he says I don't know so I just
started thinking I'll just pretend that
the stuff that they gave me was made me
made it goofy and and and you know like
you're a bit high I was doing that and
laughing and then when he feeds me said
what do you what do you want them to you
know because he cooks my brain and I
said give me dark meat chicken because I
don't you know dark weak chicken it's
hard to chew and so they had dark meat
chicken on the day and you know I'm
chewing eating my brain you know and I'm
dumb chewy because it's not an easy
thing that for at least for me and a lot
of people got sick I heard I was doing a
movie in Canada when the movie opened
and I heard that you know people some
just left even when I watched it I said
oh my god that's just disgusting
but it was fun to do
there was scenes were they were the
green thing and they had these tennis
balls or ping-pong balls kind of like so
they I don't know how they do what they
do but yeah we did have to do that
it was fun I mean if you're asked like
my best friends or my sister you know
like I can crack them up very easily and
I went I said they told me about it they
said but the director wants you to
audition for it and I saw don't care so
I went in in audition for David Mirkin
who was one of the on the ground floor
of The Simpsons and still is and he's
just a really really good director who
just has a really great comic guy so I
got it and you know the script was
really good the best thing out of all of
that was I would gene Hackman was like
one of them you know somebody that I
would like to be so I would go on days
and just watch him him work well later
so we became just a minute like like a
couple months ago I was here and this
woman comes out of the and taps me it's
a great leader I said yeah he said gene
Hackman's here he wants to say hi and I
was like just floored by it I remember I
was presenting at the Golden Globes and
I looked up and there's gene Hackman in
the middle and he gives me a wave and I
was like wow that's just unbelievable to
me that that was the aside from from
playing pretend with that stuff it was
just getting to know him was was was
really great when I come in from outside
right
it's just a nickname you've let your own
daughter seduce me do you have any idea
how much therapy you people need I've
been really fortunate to work with with
Al Pacino De Niro Gene Hackman Robert
Duvall Anthony Hopkins Vanessa Redgrave
I mean these are people that are just
unbelievable as far as I'm concerned and
how I would like my career to go it was
really well-written the director great
guy passed away really really really
really good director and the story is
just incredible I mean he was one of the
first major I mean he was getting all
the these drugs from Escobar
he was like the American contact I think
so was just incredible the lifestyle
that he led but I thought one of the
better things that Johnny did it was
really fun working on that I know what
you're up to
not everything but I get the picture and
I don't care I don't like it it's not
what I would have chosen for you but
it's your life it's got nothing to do
with me
I couldn't stop you if I wanted to could
I probably not well but it was sad
because I know what he's up to
so as a father you're not exactly
thrilled with you know your son being a
big drug dealer I remember the scene
where I'm outside and the big mansion
and you know I I definitely get what's
up and let him know that was I really
liked that movie people still talk about
that one kind of like something I've
done before I mean obviously a different
kind of person and I want to get Bradley
Cooper to it to a level so I could use
him we were able to do a combination of
the script and just adding things but
the way he shot it was very fly on the
wall and I did this movie narc and that
was very much like that
were they just camera moved you never
knew what they were where it was so you
were just playing you know pretend with
with that there wasn't like the your
shop and my shot and a lot of these were
just done and that one was just moving
the camera around
you can't walk in here yeah I can no you
can't what's that it's my house
look you assume that I have a warrant
and I'll assume that your mother has
papers okay
this won't take long
come on coffee please start upstairs
okay my babies my babies yeah tonight
we're not gonna stop very cool dude yeah
he can let Scotty be quiet I guess those
are what people remember there's
something about the bad guy I mean even
other actors who've played like intense
people they've done other types of
movies but there's just something about
those kinds of roles that stick in
people's minds Iseman yeah that what was
amazing about that is that's a true
story and when I started doing homework
on that and seeing what's kuklinski did
and how ruthless and brutal he was but
Lloyd the Mayo the character it was a
real guy a real mobster I read some of
those books about him and he was it was
just as intense as kuklinski he just
didn't want to get caught so we they
would hire him to do the hits what do
you want
closing the porn lab I'm sorry but
you're out of a job you could follow
orders
you got everything the game via Michael
Shannon what was great in that but the
scene and in the car in the back that
was my last scene and I had a flight to
leave that night and it kept getting
longer and longer and I kept getting
more and more mad so there's you know
there's all different methods to get to
where you need to be for it for the
movie and with with that I remember I
was just mad I just wanted to get out
there and I put the gun so in his face
that once it went away and was just
similar I took the gun away there was an
imprint of the barrel on his face but
that was just because I was mad cuz I
wanted to get out they would talk to
your friend Terry seems to think that
you and I are friends I can't imagine
what you've been telling them
I just like the idea of playing a
bisexual cop that that is on the take
but also loves his group of cops that he
works with was only 13 episodes so that
appealed to me Jennifer Lopez did a lot
of people knew so I knew people that
were you know would be tuned into it and
also because the part that I played I
feel extremely guilty because my
daughter killed herself so when when
they cast my daughter to do it
she would she would come but she was
coming to him in my mind I was imagining
her so it really like resonated to like
pretend you know that something horrible
happened and and because those scenes
were extremely extremely more emotional
when I did them because of the guilt of
you know what the character was going
through so there were just a lot of
levels and that were that were there I
had to fight for them and and because I
thought they were missing the boat
sometimes of what you know having such a
great character there's like a lot of
things that you guys could explore in
this that sticks with the cop show that
they finally got to but then Jennifer
just didn't want to keep doing it
because she had so many other things
going on so I mean in doing this weekly
series is it's it drained it's a lot of
work
when I got to play a lawyer the null
bound back I really liked his the
previous things that he's done and the
script was just incredible it's just
such a moving well told story he in
terms of the way he directed it and it
was just a fun part in terms of playing
I'm what I'm Susannah driver Scarlett
Johansson they they they're married they
go through they want to get divorced he
goes and and meets me and I'm the type
of lawyer who's like we're gonna have to
do this we're gonna have to do that and
everything how what it's not it wasn't
smooth and and nice it was like if we're
gonna do this we're gonna have to play
hardball I don't want to have that kind
of divorce I want to do it we'll just
you know work it out ourselves all right
fine he goes to Alan Alda who's who goes
to court with him and Scarlett Johansson
has Lord Dern as her lawyer and she's
modeled after a real intense lawyer so
he realizes that only be Alan all does
not up up to piss enough to go against
Laura Dern so he comes back to me and
hires me and then we just just a few
scenes but they were just really really
well-written it seems the whole thing is
really really good